[Music]
I'm Todd Newman I'm also from digital I
also worked on the server I have a
prepared talk so I'm gonna be trading
off eye contact for knowing what I'm
saying I hope that's acceptable
I'm gonna be describing the color maps
and visuals and so what I'm going to do
is a 20 minute talk on Bob's fifth slide
I'm gonna be talking about the new color
map types explaining how visuals
describe color maps how different
windows can use different color maps and
how different windows can achieve the
effects of using different color maps
while really using the same color map
and now my first slide work it's
right-side up it's sort of mostly
visible okay x10 only supported two
models of screen color monochrome with
the white pixel and black pixel and what
we now call pseudo color where each
pixel indexes into a common table which
has a triple of color components to send
to the red green and blue guns x10 also
only supported one color map this is
pseudo color here x11 has added one new
black-and-white color type called
grayscale and three new color color map
types called static Direction true color
grayscale produces different intensities
of black and white it's actually sort of
pseudo color with red green and blue
being set to the same thing unless you
get different levels of gray static
color is a server allocated read-only
version of pseudo color indirect color
the SIRT the pixel is decomposed into
three sets of bit fields which are used
to index into three color maps so here
I've got a pixel I'm taking the top some
bits and indexing into a red color map
and the next some indexing into green
and so on these right and and there's
true color which is direct color that
it's fixed these new color map types are
intended to better represent the
different types of Hardware on which
X might be wrong in specific there is
hardware that works as as direct color
is described here where the hardware
splits the pixel into three fixed fields
and indexes into three color Maps x10
didn't support this very well x11 also
realizes that some hardware supports
multiple depths and multiple color map
types per death and now we get the next
slide so an arbitrary screen might
support monochrome 8-bit deep pseudo
color twelve bit deep pseudo color and
twelfth deep direct color when we say
depth here we mean bits per pixel we're
not talking about screen window layers
or anything the of course the display
has some real underlying depth how many
bits are really being sent to it but if
it's being simulated and Hardware you
might as well say that it supports these
multiple deaths at connection time the
server passes the client a list of
depths it supports and the visual types
allowed at each deck and that's really
what this is visuals indicate the color
map type where to find the red green and
blue bits in a director true color pixel
how many different intensities of red
green and blue can be generated which is
what bits per RGB means and how many
entries there are in a color map it also
tells the client about the default color
map the default color map is allocated
when the server starts up and it's in
whatever sort of the natural type is for
that screen so it might be you know an
8-bit pseudo color map or whatever a
couple things to notice one is that the
color map size is independent of the
number of bits per RGB it's quite common
to have a 256 entry color map that's
sending eight bits to red 8 to green and
8 to blue which is 16 million colors and
you really wouldn't want a 16 million
entry color map you could also do it the
other way and have a larger color map
the number of colors you can generate
but I couldn't find a use for it note
also that the depth and color map size
are independent this surprised me at
first it seemed that if we had n bits
RGB that the color map should have to to
the n entries or three times to the N
for direct color but when we were
implementing color maps on Dex GPX I
found that the top two entries of the
hardware color map had been stolen for
the cursor and so if we created 256
entry color maps when we put in if we
loud the client to right into those top
two entries he'd steal the cursors color
and he could lose his cursor just go
random colors and he'd lose it as I
implied earlier x11 does allow clients
to allocate their own color maps they
don't have to use the default they can
choose from any of the supported depths
and visual types for the screen they can
fill in the color map as they like and
know that all the pixels they want will
be available if they call install color
map at the appropriate times they can
make sure that their color maps are
always installed in the hole and that
they'll always get the right colors of
course other clients could come in and
force this color map to be uninstalled
when theirs is installed if this happens
the clients window gets displayed with
whatever colors are in the current color
map and we refer to this as going
Technicolor
it would be nice of clients which didn't
need too many colors could gracefully
coexist in the default color map would
also be nice if developers could write
applications that ran on both pseudo
color and direct color without having to
worry about what the hardware really
looked like so you could just write one
interface to your color map eyelet color
planes and a lot color cells led an
application treat a set of pixels as if
they were pixels on a direct or pseudo
color map without worrying about the
underlying hardware and without
colliding with other applications pixel
needs clients use these things when they
do pixel allocations there's a very good
chance that they can coexist peacefully
before explaining full details of how
these work I'd like to discuss how
people use color and how they decide
what kind of pixel values they want to
be overly simplistic people use pixels
use color either representationally
or non representational II image
processing programs are representational
if I were to draw an apple I'd pick a
certain shade of red because that's the
color the Apple is applications in this
category of image processing like to
play games like taking the arithmetic
average of 2 pixels in order to get a
color halfway in between them such
applications work best on true or direct
color systems where the color maps been
loaded with monotonically increasing
values so that pixels with similar
values turn out to be similar colors and
I have a slide here I'm gonna get real
fancy now does this work at all
yes
so let's consider an 8-bit deep device
that the hardware has partitioned the
pixels so that the high three bits go to
red and then get looked up in the red
table the next three bits go to green
and get looked up in the green table and
the next two go to blue and get looked
up in the blue table the clients load
the tables as I've done and you probably
can't read it all in with ascending
values then it's where am I then they
can play a lot of games a lot more
easily you can do depth cueing by just
sort of reducing the pixel value in each
field you can do color blending and and
things like that as mathematical
functions
now comes the clever part if you take
this eight plane let me start again
it's a clever part doesn't it sound nice
that way since x11 uses 32-bit pixels we
could use part of the pixel say eight
bits for color planes and the other part
the remaining 24 bits the remaining 24
bits we can pick to suit our convenience
on a pseudo color device we can pick any
end bits of the pixel we could take
these or these or whatever we want to
play the color planes with and use the
rest to shuffle around and this way we
could get multiple people allocating
eight color plane bits and still all
setting their pixels into the same color
map if the hardware actually does divide
the pixel into color bit fields then we
have to put the color planes on top of
where the hardware expects to see them
so here I've done a 3/32 that is three
red three green three blue on a 24-bit
direct color system and so I put through
my three red bits where the hardware
somewhere over the hardware's red bits
and my green bits somewhere over the
hardwood hardware's green bits but we
still have a little room to play around
all these other bits aren't allocated
and I can use them there's still one
nasty allocation problem to be
considered if we're allocating one pixel
our red planes gee
Green Plains and B blue Plains and we're
allocating 1 times 2 to the ark plus G
Plus B pixels but we only want 2 to the
are independent red ones plus 2 to the G
independent green ones plus 2 to be
independent blue ones now to do the R +
G + B is of course 2 to the R times 2 to
the G times 2 to the B which is a larger
number than the sum of these things so
where did the extra pixels come from the
key thing is that I said independent
pixels let's think about just the red
pixels for a moment for each of those
are red pixel values there are 2 to the
G Plus B pixels that have that same
value and if we change any of them any
of those are pixels all 2 to the G Plus
B pixels have to have their color
changed to have worked properly on a
real direct color device this just falls
out you change the R thing it changes
the our map and every pixel changes
colors on a pseudo color device where
there's only one color map we have to
find a way to change the red component
of all those pixels this is what's
technically referred to as a bookkeeping
nightmare now to return to the non
representational color users these are
applications like business graphics and
CAD CAM a pie slice that's red
you know it's red because we like to
read electrical traces on a printed
circuit board or red so that we can tell
what layer they're on applications like
this like to play games like orange
things into pixel values and changing
one bit in the pixel to produce a
radically different color
non-representational graphics work best
on static and pseudo color devices where
the color of each pixel is independent
let's consider a hypothetical cad system
where their transistors and resistors
and other devices connected by traces
onto a printed circuit board the traces
are color-coded by layers and let's say
there are three layers where traces
interconnect between layers who want a
special color we also want to be able to
highlight a selected trace when we you
know select it by changing its pixel
value and then unhighlight it just by
restoring those pixel values
simply X soaring the pixel could produce
a pixel that we haven't allocated and
someone just before the meeting told me
about someone telling him that X was
broken because he was trying to X or
unallocated pixels so instead of doing X
or and what we're going to do is just be
able to or in a mask to change the color
and then or that or and that mask back
out to make it go away
so we one is three layer pixels one
independent fit pixel 1 intersection bit
and one highlight bit which is only 12
pixels total and we move on to my next
slide don't want to come isn't static
electricity wonderful so what we've got
here is an intersection plane a
highlight plane and then three layer
pixels again we take advantage of the
large pixels and be able to allocate the
bits for the planes wherever they fit
I've only drawn an eighth of them but
you can extrapolate a lot color cells
require that when a pixel value changes
it can be any color the user wants this
means that it must be able to set its
own red green and blue components so on
a direct color device each requested
plane must have a bit that falls into
each of the red green and blue Hardware
bit fields once again this is just a
bookkeeping problem if clients use a lot
color planes and a lot color cells that
can simulate n-bit direct and pseudo
color devices without requiring their
own hardware
excuse me without requiring their own
color Maps one client could be using a
lot color planes to allocate as I gave
in my example 3 3 2 in 256 entries and
another could be using a light color
cells to get 12 pixels and both could
run in a 512 entry default color map
with a little bit of room to spare well
so far I haven't shown you any data
structures
that's going to change this is the data
structure that I concocted for pardon no
it isn't yes yes it is
does it not show up I didn't want to
show it to you and see because people
would complain a lot
wait no what is enlightenment also
confusion on my part I apologize so
basically the color map I decided to use
just one color map for both direct and
pseudo color and I waste a couple
entries but it makes the code much
simpler and easy to read you just ignore
things so a pseudo color device is a
direct color device that only uses the
red entry I just picked red arbitrarily
so the color map has hooks to other
structures it has free pixels for each
color and I keep track of that just so
that I might be able to travel you trip
easily reject a request and then we have
color cell tables I've done the red one
in detail and the green and blue or like
it a red entry has a reference count a
shared slag and either a local color or
a shared color here we go colors right
colors allocated by alec color and a
lock named color which are two x11
requests can be used by multiple clients
this is because they basically said I
want red anybody who wants red can use
the same red each client that uses such
an entry increments this ref count when
a client relinquishes the pixel the ref
count is decremented and when the pixel
is freed
you know the pixel can be freed when the
ref count goes to zero but the client is
going to be doing things like Alec color
planes and Alec color cells which is a
little trickier this ref count gets set
to zero to minus one which basically
makes it private to that client no one
else can get that pixel the entries can
be freed when the clients done with them
okay now when I talked about allocating
the related colors what I do is related
colors I use this shared color value I
set the shared bit to true and then I
point off to a shared color so all the
related all the alec color cells pixels
that shared this red value I'm sorry
alec color planes pixels had shared the
red value would point off to this red
cell and then I changed the red cell and
then I go racing through the table
finding everyone who pointed to this red
cell and doing a store colors on them so
that the hardware was updated
appropriately this is a lot of
bookkeeping the good news is that if
you're implementing the x11 server you
don't have to do this part all you have
to do is write store colors resolve
colors install and uninstall color map
this parts done for you install and
uninstall you have to write because the
D IX layer can't tell how many color
maps your hardware supports there's some
hardware out there that can have four
installed color maps at a time and so it
has to take care of figuring out one to
throw something out and when to replace
it but in general this is all done for
you are there questions
the question is why do both pieces of
hardware cause such complexity and so
many layers I guess the answer is cuz
they're baroque because he asked why
don't we just say no to them the answer
is that when the hardware does a lot of
this stuff for itself it runs faster it
does more complex things people consider
this Hardware a win that's why they
spent so much money building it it's
nice of us to support it yeah I
described a full-blown system and some
of the most difficult things you could
want to do doing easier things is
proportionally easier and runs
proportionally faster this question over
there
some of us are in terms of the data size
you could always take pieces of this out
we're giving you code if all you say is
I only have a pseudo color and I don't
want all this okay we're trying to give
you a general piece of code since most
things aren't that in terms of size okay
there's only typical one copy of your
server running on the work
it's always easier to throw away code
once someone's written it any other
question
that's um he's describing a system sort
of like the one I put up where there's a
monochrome plane there's a monochrome
where you're viewing the world and
there's a I don't know how many bits
deep it is color view of it and you can
create a window that's monochrome and
you can create a color window and you
talk to one one way and one the other
yes that's that's a great example of
exactly why we did this before you fit
us nicely anything else we got a ringer
here okay there are in fact two kinds of
sharing and maybe my talk didn't make
that clear one kind of sharing is where
I say I've asked for four blue green and
anybody who wants blue green can get
this blue green because I'm not gonna
change it
so when I do an Alec color or an Alec
named color it hopefully comes out it
would come out of the default color map
which everybody knows how to get to and
I've guaranteed that I've asked for blue
green but I'm not going to change it so
anybody everybody can share that that's
one kind of sharing the other kind of
sharing is the one that gets involved
when you do a lot color planes on a
direct color excuse me a lot color
planes on a pseudo color map and you
need to be able to share a color value
between all the pixels that have the
same bits set for that color field
that's why there are two reference
counts one in there's one reference
count in the color map entry and there's
another one in the shared cell there are
in fact two kinds of sharing and if you
read the spec it may become clearer than
my talk made it okay
[Applause]
I feel you're gonna have to
um I'm sue Angie Brandt from digital
also and I'm another one of the
implementers of the x11
that you're going to get on the Alpha
tape over the last five months there's
been five of us who have been
implementing and designing a version of
the x11 server and what Raymond J and I
are going to explain is how we
structured the server and then describe
its main components we've designed the
server with four goals in mind
portability to multiple operating
systems and not just wedded to 4.2 unix
adaptability to multiple types of
hardware from low-end monochrome frame
buffers to high-end systems with
sophisticated hardware support for state
and windowing modularity so that you can
take out some of the software we've
written and instead use your hardware to
actually do the graphics and portability
without much loss of efficient
efficiency we'd like it to run well on
monochrome frame buffers and on that
sophisticated hardware in v10 in the v10
implementation the code was sort of
divided into two rigid parts a
device-independent part called D IX and
a device-dependent part called D DX and
we changed that we still have a DI
export part but the D DX layer has been
divided into sort of a jigsaw puzzle and
we give you the opportunity to replace
pieces or sets of pieces of the jigsaw
puzzle with the functions that your
hardware's provides and the D DX layer
sort of has these components in them
output color maps state GC is a graphics
context state manipulation which you
might have in your hardware you might
even have window management stuff in
your hardware to so you just replace the
pieces that you want in there and I'll
show you a little bit about how you do
that and the D IX layers job is similar
to what was in v10 it dispatches
requests and it manages the common data
structures and you'll notice that the
operating system is a real low class
citizen it's over there on the side
we've really tried to define a strict
interface to it so that it can be ported
to other operating systems and it's
basic job is connect
man management connection to clients and
it does scheduling between the client
connections and it's the same kind of
scheduling as in v10 just does
round-robin same kind of thing so to
obtain our goals we made heavy use of
the statefulness in the v10 protocol and
each of our major data structures
contains a set of procedures that can be
tailored to the current state of that
data structure the GC is a really good
example of that and it's divided into
basically three parts a
device-independent portion and then two
pieces that belong to the device the
first piece is a set of procedures that
implement the output calls and since
this is a common Dre the structure and
can be seen by both the independent and
the dependent portions of the code we've
provided another hook here this pointer
which allows the device to store
anything at once there and nobody else
can know about it so for instance it
might store something about the state of
the hardware or something like that and
the way this works is these procedures
down here reflect these characteristics
that are in the graphics context at this
time so instead of your polyline call
having to check all those things every
time and having all these branches you
can set the polyline call depending on
the line width and the fill style so if
I have hardware that draws single lines
really well then I stick in a polyline
call that does that when the line width
is 1 if the line width is greater than 1
and I have to do my polyline calls in
software then I stick in my procedure
that does polyline calls in software and
the reason we've done this is it makes
the draw path through the server really
fast because when the dispatcher gets a
line call and the GC it says well the GC
is all ok so I'll just indirect into the
polyline call and call that and draw my
line I don't have to do any checking so
we really think that that's going to be
a big performance win the window
structure is similar to this it has two
pieces also and windows each actually
have state to set
the border tile and we can cache around
a little information so it's faster to
draw the backgrounds and the borders
we've also provided several mechanisms
for the windows to take advantage of
hardware that does have window
manipulation things such as keeping the
windows down in the hardware or doing
the clipping calculations down there to
facilitate ports to new machines we've
provided a machine independent version
of almost everything and by machine
independent what I mean is for the
graphics calls for instance your
graphics textbook that you saw in
college had examples of routines that
were based on one thing put bits in
frame buffer or get bits from frame
buffer and so we provided algorithms
that just require you to write two
routines get bits from frame buffer and
put bits and frame buffer now you might
say that's not gonna be very fast but
it's going to let you bootstrap your
server up really quickly because you
write those through two routines you get
it up and then you can slowly replace
the replace the pieces of our jigsaw
puzzle with your you your hardware
specific stuff now what kind of things
are you going to have to replace I have
a list of those here
basically it depends on how good your
hardware is and this is sort of a list
in dumb hardware here smarter Hardware
up here at the top so as your hardware
gets better and better and better you
just keep marching up here replacing
things we expect people with monochrome
frame buffers just to just do a few of
these things down here and then as they
get more sophisticated they'll just
start walking up here I don't expect
anybody to replace the dispatcher it's
always going to be up there grabbing
things off the network as as part of the
user code rather than down in Hardware
so Raymond is going to talk about the
port that we've done of all of our stuff
to a monochrome frame buffer and then
talk about some porting strategies
all right my name is Raymond Roy I'm the
last person you'll hear from working on
the x11 server I think and I'm going to
tell you most of the same things that
Sue did except I'm going to go at it
more from the bottom up instead of the
top down and try to tell you what how we
think you should how how our design
wants to be ported to various kinds of
hardware and since all of the boxes you
saw in Susa
previously can conceivably be replaced I
thought I would take one as a specific
example and we'll talk about how you can
run an X 11 server on hardware with
graphics output support that we didn't
envision but you have to remember all
through this that we could you could do
the same thing for example to the code
that manages the window tree or the code
that deals with the color maps or the
code that does clipping calculations
so when you look at your alpha test tape
your beta test tape and want to get X
running on your favorite piece of
hardware you'll see that there are five
the GC has this procedure vector in it
and there are five things you have to
replace there these three here the fill
spans set spans and gets pans what fill
spans does is it looks at the state in
the GC it takes a list of scan lines and
fills each of those scan lines according
to the current fill rule that is it uses
the current color if the fill style is
filled with solid color the current tile
if the fill style is filled with a tile
the current stipple if the current style
is stipple fill set spans is like fill
spans but a little different it takes a
list of scan lines and a list of full
pixel values to put in it you can that
would be used for example in a copy area
routine we'll we've used gets fans to
read an entire scan line so we have full
pixel values not just something not just
some algorithmic pattern to put in these
two over here validate GC and create GC
are used to deal with the state and the
procedure vectors for the output calls
we call create GC when a client says
create me a GC for this screen at this
diff at that point the hardware should
fill in the procedure vector in the GC
with procedures that match the default
state of the GC and furthermore each GC
like all our other internal structures
has a field in it called device private
and the hardware is free to put anything
in there at once we assume generally
that it will put a pointer in there and
the point will pry it off point off to
Hardware context associated with this
graphics context for example validate GC
is not something you see in the protocol
we use that internally when the
dispatcher gets a graphics request it
looks at the GC and notices if it's been
changed since the last output requested
gee see if it has it calls GC with the
drawable this output request is going to
and the end the GC and the mask telling
it which bits have changed the validate
GC code then ought to go through and
modify any hardware state that it needs
to to deal with the new state blocks it
could replace procedures in the
procedure vector and that sort of thing
so validate GC is really where where the
hardware gets come and say I know what
this drawing request is I know how I
want to do it now if you have those five
sue said to but the number seems to get
unfortunately larger every time I look
but I think it's going to stay at five
but for now if you implement those five
routines your server will run slowly but
it will run this this is important I've
always thought it's really neat to see
your ex server come up for the first
time and sort of an order of precedence
there are other routines that you will
probably want to replace copy area
because you use that to scroll in X term
and everybody wants X term to go fast
text out because everybody uses text
even if they're a graphics application
they'll have menus and so on and
furthermore there's a lot of hardware
that has has text support in it polyline
is in there because if you are
interested mostly in software there's a
lot of software that uses uses polylines
for dragging outlines of things around
in paint packages or drawing window
borders for window managers and if you
build hardware you've probably put
Hardware line code in your you've
probably line cut line support in your
hardware and you want to show it off in
your X server and fill rectangle we use
to clear window backgrounds and so on
now one thing to notice is that fill
rectangle isn't really how we clear out
window backgrounds on the window also
has a procedure vector in it which you
can replace at a later date and this way
you can take advantage of the fact that
we know well in advance what kind of
background your window has we know you
have a solid
background or a tiled background so you
can put in the appropriate code since we
fill window backgrounds fairly often
you probably want you probably to avoid
all the extraneous tests and so forth to
see what you're filling with now we've
provided some useful tools to help you
out with this there's there's the
Machine independent output code that su
talked about and it's a set of code that
implements all of the x11 graphics
output primitives and Clips them to
bunches of rectangles and so on and you
can replace those or modify them or
whatever they will they're guaranteed to
turn on the bits that the protocol says
you should turn on in the frame buffer
we provide is another set of routines
that do rectangle arithmetic they'll do
intersections of bunches of rectangles
subtract one rectangle from another that
sort of thing and that's useful for the
clipping calculation um in x11
the client can specify a clip mask
unlike an x10 where you only you had to
pass it in with the request or clip to
the window and you can use these two
composite together the window clip and
the client clip so you can sort of do
all your clipping at once no for dumb
frame buffers we provide a sample
implementation that is we've written
copy area and text output and polyline
and fill rectangle for one bit deep
frame buffers where all the pixels are
contiguous in a row no interlace or
anything silly like that so the this
code is almost machine independent but
it's not really because it assumes that
pixels are one bit deep and that pixels
come in memory one right after the other
now this is a problem because on some
displays the bits number 0 to 31 and 0
to 31 or not of our hardware they go
31200 and some of them byte swap and do
other things so in the monochrome frame
buffer routines if you write they get
bits and a put bits that we tell you
starting a bit logical bit and on the
screen turn on the following some number
of bits if you write code that does that
the correct way in your screen at
compile time you'll automatically get
all of the monochrome frame buffer stuff
working on your hardware and we have
some evidence that this scheme works all
right
x11 is has already been ported to
several things or partially ported we
run on the back station to with the
monochrome frame buffer that's been our
base development machine for the server
we run on the IBM PC RT which is another
monochrome frame buffer but it's
interesting because the bits on the
screen are numbered differently and it's
been shown that by rewrite and get bits
input bits you just recompile and it
runs we run on digital's GPX which is a
color machine it has hardware support
for some but not all drawing operations
for example it has hardware support for
polygons so you could hook out the
polygon code in the GC to fill polygons
on it we run on the vs 100 mostly for
historical reasons yes um it's it's much
harder to run x11 on the vs 100 and was
to run x10 on the vs 100 anyway the via
the vs 100 is another monochrome device
with some hardware drawing support and
the port 2 it was relatively painless of
course we couldn't use the monochrome
frame buffer routines for it because you
can't get it bits but we use the Machine
independent stuff and that works X has
also been experimentally ported to an
all-singing all-dancing 3d graphics
engine with multiple color maps hardware
support for the window tree hardware
implementation of lots of the x11
primitives and that sort of thing and
that port is interesting because it in
theory exercise is the multiple color
map stuff
and also deals with wholesale
replacement of all our procedure vectors
you know replaces the window treatment
of relation stuff with its hardware
hooks and so on so it's often been
complained that all of this is more
complex than necessary so I thought I'd
give two examples of how this whole
calling sequence might work so for a
monochrome frame buffer we've been asked
the dispatcher has been told
draw me a line we noticed that the GC is
the same way it's always been there no
state changes so we just in direct
straight through the through the
polyline field of the GC which calls the
monochrome frame but for polyline
routine we draw the line all right now
consider that the user or the client
program changes the GC and says I want
line width of 5 and I want my fill style
to be stippled so the dispatcher when it
gets this request on this window or even
this draw will remember that your output
code has to be able to draw to main
memory or to the screen if it gets it
notices that the GC has changed so it
calls the the validate routine we've
provided that validate routine goes
through and notices that we can no
longer use our nice fast monochrome
frame buffer line to code so it swaps in
another thing it swaps in the Machine
independent poly line code it returns
the dispatcher then calls through the GC
and ends up in the routine and my poly
line now mi poly line converts wide
lines to polygons and then calls the
fill polygon could so it converts the
lines to polygons then it calls to the
fill polygon vector now if we were on
the GPX we would go straight to the
hardware at this point we don't because
our dumb frame buffer doesn't know about
polygons so we go to our machine
independent polygon filling code it
actually goes to the frame buffer and
turns bits on so it for each some number
of scan lines it
offers up a set of scan lines then calls
the GCS fill spans filled the fill spans
that we selected and invalidate was fill
scan lines with the current stipple
pattern the bits go on on the screen and
you get your wide line now this isn't as
slow as it might appear um it turns out
that for things like this the the
computational overhead is is much
greater than actually having to go to
the frame buffer and turn the bits on so
unless you have help actually
calculating how to turn the bits on
which which is what a graphics engine
does for you this is all right so on the
GPX you would start hitting the hardware
here and on maybe some a very smart
device you would actually get to the
hardware at that point so that's all
I've had to say I guess I can answer
questions until we've run out of time
and one is a t x86 personal computers
which there exist maybe
we we the implementers and I I can't say
anything for project Athena they'll have
to answer themselves
we'll stop implementing when he finished
when we finished the alpha test code and
give it to these people there's nothing
preventing you from porting it to any
hardware you want we think and we
haven't gone to go on extremely low end
there are a couple things that we've
kind of assumed that were already
brought up a little bit in the color map
stuff we assume for example reasonable
about reasonable amounts of memory um oh
I don't know I don't see why we couldn't
run on say a 640k machine on the other
hand all the 640k machines I know have
ridiculous segmented architectures that
make a lot of this a lot harder but go
ahead and try I think I think you can do
it I really do no all we use no
floating-point not true it turns out
what we have to use fixed point for a
couple things but we reduce it to a
minimum or we true most algorithms can
be done an integer if you think about it
long enough 32 bits 6 16 bits
well since x11 coordinate system is 16
bits it's probably okay to use a 16 bit
machine yes
what sort of difficulty this that's
about it that's as far as we go
that's one two three four four layers
deep one one way you can get around this
is take our machine independent code and
replace the calls out with just
hardwired go touch my frame buffer now
yes the question is how much what do we
go through to clip text and it turns out
the text is pretty easy to clip because
unless unless you're doing say kerning
which may give you funny shapes at the
ends
you can't the string defines a rectangle
and you can do a lot of the clipping by
taking the rectangle the text will hit
and intersecting it with where you want
to go so you can almost clip on a purse
string basis
or is it assumed that it will be safe um
ah clipping it is assumed all of these
everything in the GC except set spans
Phil spans and gets pans clips
right we
thank you can you could typically very
easy to figure out that that a character
writer is entirely inside entirely
outlier on the border so so typically
you just let the whole pile of
characters and worry about the one which
is on the edge and when you're done of
an extended raster
so that you've got this virtual buffer
behind it explained the top down
so thank you you cover it up and then
uncover it what all I've done to save
the information
or has it
all right I think what you're asking is
is is how do we do back in the store is
that what you're asking there there
there there there are hooks in the
server there there there there are hooks
in the server to allow you to implement
backing store and we provide a sample
version of machine independent backing
store showing you how to use those yes
we have we've played with it some
the output on the enforcement
our copy by
no no we haven't but I've thought about
it and I don't it's I think it would
work well I think you could probably do
it if you pretended that your your
hardcopy device was say another screen
remember that a server supports multiple
screens and you just draw two windows on
that screen I think that would be fine
yes point that logic functions that read
the destination back will not work on
your printer yes oh do we have network
every day I mean can you write us mail
no you have to go through Ralph's wing
project Athena Jim gave all that
information already yes
we provide a black box and you fill it
in and in our implementation ultrix is
4.2 we use select but there's no reason
why you couldn't yeah oh yeah there's a
black box it's called wait for something
well remember we only validate if we
notice something's changed now there's
something I didn't tell you which is
that an optional thing you can put in is
that we will call out to the hardware
whenever the GC has changed if the
hardware wants that turns out for a lot
of hardware it is hardware without a lot
of hardware hardware internal stuff it's
better to batch up all the changes and
do them all at once it's also easier to
deal with clipping in case the windows
moved
we three can use that type that's Phil's
question that's basically a protocol
question there's nothing a protocol
allows you to do that now nothing
prevent you from simplemente extension
which did that and telling that
extension to do it there's no way in the
x11
protocol make that request
okay
[Applause]